hurry up starving sorry sorry sorry so
sorry I just had to grab my wah
[Music]
gentlemen fine I was trying something
and it didn't work
[Music]
so there's this suitcase okay yeah okay
be kind I don't have a models body like
you
come on show what you get Fred Astaire
Gene Kelly Liberace
Diane Keaton Roger that okay Charles
you're not Scottish yeah get back in
there Braveheart
summer linen suit casual a classic
actually not bad one question can you
see my underwear ah song why are you
wearing a thong
it's my Something Borrowed get back in
there is it better on you
this is the elite party squad that is
assuming the captain is ready to let
loose captain I don't think so I want
you guys to think of me as one of the
boys so tonight I'll be swapping out my
captain's hat for my Kangol hat call me
Raymond okay Raymond in the can go ahead
I will definitely call you Raymond
Raymond to the king go ahead Bongiorno
Bongiorno
pretty cool stume huh stem short for
costume ah
all right let me guess you are dumpy
Chuck Norris
no don't be wrong Weasley no guys stop
it
he put thought into his costume and he
is obviously Miranda from Sex in the
City
guys I'm Mario Batali multo Mario
celebrity chef ginger Prince of Little
Italy is he also a homeless troll doll
cuz the other guy got homeless troll
doll sweepit alley costume dude thank
you there's a man with impeccable taste
he bit a guy's butt off at a WNBA game
Eric Stoltz for mask I'll take it
captain the kids want to know where a
Polly the pigeon is I told him he got
sucked up into an airplane engine is
that all right I can't put that pigeon
head on Gina
one chest defeated me this is how it
ends with me standing on the
urine-soaked floor of an elementary
school bathroom and a third-rate bird
costume good morning everyone
oh my goodness Sarge what are the
chances I say zero
oh I mean when Genevieve gotten these
suspenders I thought I'd lean into it go
for the whole look but I didn't want to
step on your toes that being said you
know what this means don't do this
Charles oh it's already done gather
round y'all it's time to play who wore
best I'd really rather not because
you're a little chicken who wore it best
who wore it best
who wore it best what come on you should
change Boyle not here
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh mister fart you look perfect so some
of the costume is that all you got
hardly every time a go-cart drives by I
want you to scream and this is very
important me so corny so what do you
think I don't love the sash but it's
fine I'm just gonna get it what that's
the first one you tried on I once let
you look at 54 different accordion
folders and not buy any of them due to
weak tabs I file hard I need strong tabs
I just don't want to take up any more
time your breaks not even a quarter done
I'll stay another ten minutes you'll
stay until I dismiss you Irene music now
spin all units 1033 are libo they gon
smith purpose heading east on Baltic
we're on Baltic well crap there with him
[Music]
[Music]
damn SARS maybe I do like the sash okay
muchachos let's roll up on these
muchachos great start and I love your
double use of muchachos hey it's CJ by
the way
good morning boy it's Halloween I'm
surprised you didn't put on a costume I
was going to you sir but then I decided
screw that jazz well I'm the only one
who ever dresses up no one ever gets my
costume and they make fun of me so I'm
done these people don't deserve my
dress-up gifts Charles
seriously no costume what the hell
Charles where's your Halloween spirit
but you guys always make fun of me I
have never once insulted you in my life
especially these Ivy your appearance
yeah man we always loved your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and/or thing yes I do remember
sir permission is sprint to my car get
my emergency costume does it matter if I
say no yeah
a bam bam boom where you dressed up you
look like an idiot yeah what are you
supposed to be a sassy car mechanic no
come on he's clearly the rejected
pop-tarts mascot harry pop-tart I am NOT
You Know Who I am squad that's enough
you're making Boyle for bad on purpose
he's Elvis yes
Elvis Stojko the Canadian figure skaters
[Music]
guess who just came from the PS 321
Thanksgiving Parade Charles you actually
my Charles I'm Tommy gobbler and I'm
stopped
with Thanksgiving happiness Oh gobble
gobble
seriously I'm Tommy gobbler
you silly pilgrim ok Tommy gobbler these
are the Davidson's they want to know
what happened to their missing
grandmother I have some deeply tragic
news for you you guys this is gonna be
fine I mean Terry's our boss and he
comes with us every year correction you
bring vacation Terry and he is no man's
boss when the slippers are filled
Tammy all right listen up but you're
about to see is highly disturbing but
please no comments this man is in pain
so above all else
be kind good morning boy let's just get
it out there
Vivian broke up with me last night I'm
sorry chucklebunny Charles wait yes your
food dehydrator it's official weddings
off and this is what I'm like now life
is a pit excuse me I don't understand
did you already have a matrix get up at
home for some reason no Jeana I bought
this with the money I was going to spend
on our honeymoon to Cape Canaveral I'm
so sorry buddy
don't be I'm settling into the darkness
nicely I definitely get you now what you
got there boiled eggs in a bag nothing
brings me joy anymore not even food now
I will need for sustenance
hey hey are you guys wearing one scarf
yep Charles forgot his this morning it's
actually quite romantic I think he did
it on purpose
let's just say I definitely did it on
purpose now twirl me darling you've got
all right you guys are adorable
hey I love the sweater he's slaying a
night lady killer well we shall see what
we shall see
no you're dressed exactly like the lady
killer damn it she's Jeffrey Dahmer's
corduroys all over again oh my god
Rosa's wearing pink Rosa's wearing pink
are we sure it's not a white shirt
that's just been bloodied in a
motorcycle crash maybe it wasn't her
does she have a twin sister if Rosa had
a twin she would have eaten her in the
womb wait pull it stop how come none of
you teased her about it it's Rosa she's
scary you guys are unbelievable I once
wore a tie with a splash of purple you
guys called me mr. grapes for two years
God about mr. graves if I wore pink
shirt you tear me to shreds
well yeah but you'd look like a My
Little Pony with a gun let me guess your
theater club is putting on grease and
you're playing a pink lady
if Boyle was wearing a pink shirt I get
it that's larious what's happening
Rosa's the one wearing pink and it's
gorgeous
wish I could pull that off dream on
strawberry shortcake yeah nice try mr.
grapes
[Music]
[Applause]
you